yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing the lobster and its rapid game
on ditches quite unmistakably yeah it
looks ok yeah yeah Windows setup is ok
[Music]
it's a little bit tricky out of the
browser because somehow you can easily
screw it up okay so what Cullen
Alekhine's probably I don't know
yep c4 it is the most popular move and
four points it's going to be not so easy
I have looked at this only briefly and
yeah can't say I'm an expert
okay so this is correct
yeah g6 is right and now now
there's the big issue hmm I think Bishop
e7 is right I think just Bishop e7 d5
I have totally forgotten the theory but
should G for I think is not that good I
think there should be seven was correct
and it says this is an extremely
extremely long line okay but should be
true d5 is the it's the aggressive one I
mean this is also aggressive but d5 is
the move that tries to wipe out black
simply mmm-hmm okay and here
yeah and I think f6 is correct
but I have no precise idea is this I
mean I think 21 tweeny one rupee one
yeah all the others that that also makes
perfect sense
hmm Queen to e7 I defy office hmm d5 can
be in issue maybe just 95 I think this
is right but I have no exact
recollection and rook e8 d5 I can also
play rooty eight maybe yeah it looks
very logical putting this opposite the
White Queen so then a six pawn is a
little bit weak oh that's the wrong way
to put it it is potentially weak let's
say but not easy to to do to do many
concrete things with how to attack the
white so what's going on here so how do
I play this in general I would want to
increase the pressure on that Center
Bishop g4 is a move that looks logical
in that regard try to maybe capture and
take on the phone
white what does white want to do
potentially d5 but it's not really
that's not looking really scary at the
moment looks like I mean those pieces on
the e-file I'll lose this looks like
very normal no actually yeah I'm going
for it
putting more pressure on the form
sorry after work
sorry about that I got a text message
message and briefly had to answer okay
so what's the point I would say I'm as
usual a simple really a simpleton I want
to take on a three take on d4 so what is
why it's idea against that we'll see him
one thing that is somehow some ops
unsettling a little bit is that the
Queen and rook here are in that diagonal
so somehow Bishop c5 would win the
exchange so I'm always kind of I'm
looking for this d5 and d5 kind of moves
okay that's interesting
he just tries to take on f6 that's a
good move I did not really ask myself
what is what is my opponent smooth if I
would have done that I would have
spotted two Satyam hmmm very very bad
now very annoying for for black
my position is really terrible no I
cannot prevent him to take f6 and that's
my best piece crap Wow
while their position is really really
bad now but it's not even slightly worse
it's just completely terrible
[Music]
bah and he's just threatening to take
and play Bishop g5 I probably have to go
age six in this position
wow what a disaster
Wow - Bishop Bishop before wasn't it
totally Datuk move
remarkable I am NOT pre moving like this
I should focus a little bit okay but
Queen takes is probably ridiculous ng
295 some this one Ned's it's it's super
simple now White has just the better
structure and the bishop pair so again
my position is almost unplayable in I
don't be sixes absolutely it sucks
completely now
t5 is also very close close to working
yeah I'm thinking how to improve the
night now on v6 somewhere to f5 or so
would be good but it takes takes ages
and I'm a bit concerned that t5 works at
some point okay I can take and go 95
probably I totally suck so that was a
really bad mistake I'm sorry for
repeating this but I'm really upset that
I've that I did not have played this and
I didn't really think about whites reply
994 is just totally off me
[Music]
one thing I'm totally certain of he said
I think that when people blame me I
think they'd given the extra one extra
percent and sometimes they would you
stronger than usual let's say because
they simply know where there will be on
on TV in a way as you see from the
dialogue I think people actually are
able to yeah mobilize their strength a
little bit better okay I'm trying 96 to
f5 is the idea I think that even h3
Bishop Bishop age 5 and G for those kind
of things are extremely annoying ok so
the Queen to c2 hmm what is that doing
it covers it to the dead stayed in the
the main thing but instead a big deal
Knight g5 might be an idea
but I can answer that with Bishop f5
everything yeah so that doesn't work
96 mmm so what is the big problem there
I mean it isn't all that bad is it
Quincy - Quincy - was a bit lame I
thought maybe I'm overlooking something
again but here I feel Knight f5 is some
some kind of threat
hmm it's not that's not so bad 95 is
also big tempo in this night CH idea is
really based on that old rule that you
should try to improve your worst piece
then I don't be six really sucked
whenever five it makes perfect sense
gaining that tempo and then maybe being
able to take every take you four yes
I expected that move so what now I can
take some material here 95 g5 rook takes
f5 is hanging
and d6 is hanging with the temple but
Knight f5 is always a big fork so so
okay let's think about it I take f1 rook
takes 95 d5 Knight f5 alright it's it's
okay it's really okay
is there anything else I can take now
only five de five take f1 edits
basically the same position
it's basically the same position okay
and there should be okay I really should
be okay down yeah yes you take with the
rook and now maybe I should have thought
for a moment but I think it should be
okay here
Bishop g4 93 is definitely fine and I
don't believe in Bishop a7 and that
that's not something I feel is
appropriate rather Bishop f2 on
something he actually does take that
okay if it isn't this good for black but
what what don't I understand here feel
like I'm missing something what do and
the rook is attacked as everything as a
checked
so the rook
[Music]
first of all I can always just take on
g4 Queen takes Queen c5 check King H 125
that's just a flat pawn for nothing if I
grab on everyone Bishop e6 King f8 Queen
f5 k e8 Queen g6 is a draw so Bishop e6
King F King h8 Bishop f5 this is the
thing a threatening made I can check on
c5 and that's it
probably
hmm yeah it doesn't seem to work it
doesn't seem to work in this long line
and it takes okay take that one take C
six H eight Bishop f5 and check on c5
King takes f1 this is the problem and I
don't have a check
rook t1 King e2 leads nowhere yeah I
mean this is okay but it's probably not
easy to win take the pawn so the key and
a kind defense concept worked winning
the e5 pawn okay that was not the e5
pawn originally but the D pawn so this
the Czech threat and b7 is hanging so
probably going to cover this Queen f7 is
just a check
yeah so rookie - maybe or let's first
let's get into a setup where everything
is protected King is reasonably saved
there I would love to play hooky - next
Note 3 second increment so there
probably won't be a time when yeah that
makes perfect sense
covering a bit so how to do this
rookie one is probably on White's agenda
yeah it's definitely tough to do much
it's also good to check over here
hmm
I don't see a really clear concept how
to make headway here no it's probably
just really dry
yeah it's pretty dry taking Andrew have
seven is probably okay okay for off a
white hmm really it looks a bit passive
hmm I'm a bit surprised that you played
that somewhat passive move it might not
be the end of the world but still but a
bit surprised yeah
Queen d1 probably
why give it out I mean I can also give
that pawn up and pushy form
hmm come on with this time to the time
ticking down I prefer an ending ok so
this is a checked c5
so
mm okay rookie six look f6p seven hmm
is just a drawer problem it is just a
drawn
he goes in the fourth I'd take check and
take one the second I'd check and take
ye goes back to h2 which is fairly
passive
okay he goes for the for the passive
move and now we will trade down to
something where I probably have have an
extra pawn at the end maybe maybe not
actually rookie six yeah it's just a
draw I'm slightly more active here but
okay it's still just an office but you
can you can try
try to check and then kingi five okay
so so the draw but what I mean this pawn
is worth noting the a to pawn he has to
watch out a little bit
no checking is wrong I have an enormous
space advantage but it is like very
likely wrong but yeah I can get to g3
which is a really great spot for the
rook putting pressure on the pawn and if
he goes a for that bonus this pawn is
going to be lost very lightly because he
cannot support it
he's in such a passive position that he
cannot support the pawn like a 5 I can
check and probably win the pawn so doing
here [ __ ] before yeah now I can place
you three actually let's do it
and it's not so easy if he goes here I
can take and he cannot go on to the B
file so I have to go here for King III
yeah King D 3
ah I didn't think about this move I damn
it I didn't think about this one shoot
that's that's a shame cannot take the
check here rook F - maybe he offers me
draw it is probably a drawn King here
yeah yeah sorry he'd simply hit the
wrong button now did I spoil the wind at
the end hmm okay kind of curious though
I feel like a head oven at the end some
maybe not yeah see three yeah good see
we'll see the computer and analysis here
is running yeah and let's start I mean
we had this other kinds for pawns and
cast lots f6
this is correct yeah I'm totally sorted
even here I'm fairly positive that this
is a theory theoretical line and now the
engine has fired yeah I remember
something like that in my files but I
couldn't quite piece it together one
thing I know the movie I played is
rubbish you know this is this is really
bad that's a really balanced 94 it's a
really good good reply yeah and now I'm
really in trouble
yeah aged six kind of have to know that
ticking is very natural I think it would
be surprising if this is bad then b3 is
yeah must be okay
so back here and Quincy - yeah Quincy -
is not accurate that that's what I am
what I thought h3 yeah the ideas if I go
here this even g4 yeah and the engine
control said this is strong as I already
mentioned in the brought in the
broadcast here in the yeah this is this
is wrong
so probably mission f5 is indicated by
the competent d5 yeah d5 that position
sucks yeah III was excellent forward
after Quincy - I'm back in the game and
after 95 I'm definitely okay so this
unlike this tasty six yes and now we
should have two I expected but he took
and that that is wrong I guess yeah I
cannot take the the rook respect look at
this bishop here King h8 Bishop f5 and I
cannot win yeah if I check he can take
this and there is nothing I can do here
to avoid to draw yeah King j8y can at
least draw maybe he can do more so I had
to take and play this this apana what
strong chance I still still okay yeah so
at the end we got long ending and I'm
kind of curious if there was a winning
chance yeah yeah I felt I'm getting some
bad this is a really annoying position
to play but probably probably I spoiled
it somewhere and this and probably wrong
King defaults indicated by the engine so
but can I win after King before
whenever I go see three the stinking to
be three
they're probably nothing the engine
gives zero and the computer should play
perfectly him yeah all in all I think a
reasonably well played game I'm really
unhappy about my Bishop g4 move that was
pretty pretty bad that was pretty bad
then somehow I have fought myself out of
it yeah roughly here I was probably the
moment where I had the biggest advantage
but still not much still much yeah okay
guys thanks for watching